my grandfather was a very famous
commercial real estate developer but
more famous for being in many ways a a
philosopher about cities in the 40s and
50s he was very very ahead of the curve
in terms of predicting what would happen
if we failed to invest in the inner city
and kept and keep it a vital place that
people wanted to not only come to work
but live he kind of predicted the the
phenomenon of flight to the suburbs by
the middle and upper middle class and
the collapse of the inner city he talked
about the perils of low density
development you know development based
on the highway as opposed to mass
transit and the way that that that would
create sprawl he saw a problem that a
lot of people were sort of just writing
off as a permanent a permanent condition
in American life people were saying well
forty million people living below the
poverty line and these decrepit
neighborhoods and abandoned buildings
and this is just a part of the inherent
reality of American capitalism where
there's going to be a certain part of
the market that the that the for-profit
real estate market and the government
don't cover that gets let falls between
the cracks and when a lot of that stuff
came true in the 60s and 70s he was he
was looked at by a lot by a new
generation of progressive urban planners
and urban thinkers as a real visionary
he basically said why are we accepting
this condition why are we accepting the
conventional wisdom that this is a
problem that can't be solved that's
insane and he rallied he pulled in a lot
of really young and brilliant people he
pulled him out of the financial sector
and he sort of said we need to envision
we need to come up with a mechanism that
that makes it make sense to invest in
that part of the housing market and so
he and some very young very brilliant
people came up with the architecture of
of what became the low-income housing
tax credit the federal low-income
housing tax credit it was a
revolutionary idea it was um it was a an
idea that of how you could incentivize
people banks and companies to make
investments in equity funds that
invested in affordable housing by
through a federal tax credit program
that just gave it a slightly boosted
return through federal tax credits and
everybody across all the whole political
spectrum Republican Democrat loved this
program because it addressed a need
without throwing government money at it
it it incentivized the you know banks
and businesses to invest and get a
return but it aimed it at a part of the
marketplace that wasn't being dealt with
for the lawyers and the kids studying
finance and business and housing and
urban planning you know those are the
ideas that that the next wave is gonna
have to come up with and it's gonna come
in areas that people aren't expecting it
to right now it's going to come in
things like like energy or efficiency
never assumed that there isn't a
solution to a complex problem there it's
usually just because somebody's not
paying it not willing to put in you know
the time and the brainpower
most people are on cruise control most
of the time they just are there they're
cruising along taking things as they are
people who are innovators tend to
recognize a need before other people
that's all you know I mean they sort of
say I want this and it's missing but
then they don't stop at that point you
know they don't sort of go oh that's a
bummer they go hmm like there must be a
way to do that